you co-wrote and you directed this movie
but you're also you have the distinction
of being in the original predator I
think we have a photograph here yeah and
he thought at all of doing a cameo and
saying I'm alive you know there's a
picture on the line of which my name as
the character in a pie like guts
yeah so it's a we actually had a bucket
of pig guts that was me
yes movie so we could try to spin that I
think these days you were reanimated
emergency surgery they stuffed you back
into another body you know they could do
anything and I'm 40 feet up hanging from
a tree yeah so one of your concerns is
you wanted this predator to be scarier
than some of the recent predators is
that fair to say
um I think because the predator look is
so iconic time so instantly recognizable
I mean you could walk out in comic-con
and see a pretty serviceable predator
just walking around yeah so what he
looks like although you don't want to
change that it's not gonna scare people
so much anymore so you gotta go back to
the way I think that they behave how
they how deadly they are so these things
and for our purposes well first off we
got no rating so this thing can strike
he can retreat and he can
that's right previous some of the
previous predators have had like PG
ratings and I think a few of them had a
G rating it's true there's one where he
goes to an island and he meets candy and
they yeah that pattern his name was
cuddles we have a look at the the new
predator let's take a look at it right
now
his yeah the mouth opens in like 45
different ways no what we will be strove
for was a predator that's been bred as
an assassin so he's basically
incorporates traits from other species
even that these predators have hunted
around the galaxy so this one opens his
mouth
really big it bites off your head yeah
you like that guess I really enjoyed
that a lot that was fantastic
shooters that would be huge improvement
over the rated G touring company a
predator
you